c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche sur sous jacent j'ai tout à
chacun de la géométrie et pose toi avec
question ce qu'on va voir hadji
l'écriture et versa mais je n'avais
jamais remarqué ça parce que moi j'ai
une poche donc j'ai pas vraiment le
genre de provins je vis de ma poche
n'importe où mais comme isabelle
morini-bosc mais va toucher pas parce
que on est bien dans ses chiottes et les
sciences
il a deux fils pourquoi ce qu'on essaie
de mettre le film
à oui parce que c'est rigolo pas de
regret parce que tu as envie de route de
rentrer dès que tu vois un truc qui tu
as envie de te voilà en fait ce qui
n'est pas faux en soi voilà
[Musique]